okay I'm back I hope that's okay
let's accept a challenge okay so now we
move on to the 3/2 portion oh I have to
update the score to two and a half for
me wait I'm playing white again it
should be rotating colors
unless okay as long as like we have the
same number of white and blacks it
should be okay as I was white the last
game he's playing d6 oh let's play this
okay so he's playing some weird stuff
it's not easy to transition from ten
minute to 3-2 in like a serious formats
just have to move much quicker I'm used
to taking my time play c6 usually h3
Bishop e3 and then I have some tricky
move that I usually like to play which
is Queen B 1 to a 2 he really wants to
play b5 I might have to allow it maybe D
5 D 5 let's play d5 attempting to not
allow b5
yeah and now let's do this preventing
that h5 he wants to play f5 let's put
the bishop here and put the 9 and C 4
it's playing very quickly it's not a bad
system for black 4 for blitz
go play this if b5 I taken play Knight
a5 and invade c6 so a big difference
between this and previous time controls
that there's increments so if we get low
on time we can still kind of survive yes
I'm trying to control f5 as much as
possible I want to play rook a3 b3 might
be slightly psychotic looks like fun
maybe g3 g3 and then h4
Wow this is complicated takes takes
maybe night c4 we trade Queens let's
throw in h4 he's gonna play Queen h6 let
me trade once and then maybe Brooke d1 I
don't know
take stakes then he's gonna have f4 so
maybe takes takes rook t1 is a way to go
take once at least it looks very risky
I'm defending my Queens so my knight son
tinned I'm scared of f4 but it opens up
my bishop so it's kind of risky for both
of us efore a while are their tactics
like takes their I feels like there
should be something takes their their
takes mmm let's move back safety first
now f4 is various that's also very scary
to play this probably
position turns sour very quickly but I'm
still kind of alive Knight takes I still
want to take on f5 I'm not seeing how it
works I win a couple of pawns lose a
piece probably good move let's play
nighty to preparing is he gonna play off
for f4 might just crushed me so I can't
take my spawn because Knight f3 it
doesn't play off for okay so now I'm
doing okay Queen e2 will come soon my
nights are happy
Knights are in their natural habitats
frontal pawns d5 is defended b5 might
come but then it opens a file which file
its take you might take with rook few
ticks with that I play this one invade
on the a file you king h1 prophylactic
move or something
rook a8 some move I guess when I play
rook ei1 this is not an advertisement
for EA Sports takes takes ok let's play
rookie a1 we'll trade maybe a pair of
rooks and my rook will be active maybe I
can get through to the King Queen G a
while so I could take but that doesn't
really do much let's attack the D pawn
do you pause not too offended by
anything not even by tactics
how does he defend in 9899 f7 okay maybe
night II 6 NE 6 is interesting cuz it
obstructs the bishop like if he takes
takes I win d6 and this side probably
take on the square we can trade on e6
things are transforming I play rook aid
in the end we trade more well when the
e4 thing looking for tactics but not
seeing anything
New York a7 first player ok 7 first not
sure what that does maybe I want to
double up on the seventh rook c7 no okay
we're trading
b5 s hanging but my nights hanging 97 is
a move
taking now any seven doesn't look right
so let's play 93 be 5 so attacks see for
logical you play Bishop h3 better
diagonal I'm accessing f5 for some piece
you might play d5 it's gonna get wild
Queen there maybe rook c7 threatening
rook c8 being very sneaky King g7 Knight
f5 time scramble there is 2 second
increment though probably Queen g8 back
and then Knight f5 maybe first rook c8
bad move takes takes I want to keep my
rook it's more active
want to find out a five soon maybe put
the coin on d4 it's a good square for
the Queen Queen d2 maybe d1 going to d4
aligned with the king it's not trade
rooks okay this mites kind of pin to the
other night Knight f5 or 95 could be
coming to you six is just hanging let's
just take that Oh F five it also while
this is just falling apart for black
forgot f5 was a square let's just take
it okay
three and a half still many more games
to go rematch
clicking rematch there you go okay so
I'm black so we've had a few openings so
far I'm gonna play e6 play a qgd he
might play another cattle on b3 I'll
play the line with a5 a5 a4 kinda
offbeats but still playable
can I take I take immediately trying to
remember this do I play d4 maybe I play
d4 d4 can I remember this yeah d4
because if might be 5 I have knight c6
85 useful and we'll have a reversed
Benoni maybe somewhat similar to the
structure we had last game he has Bishop
Bishop f4 I'll survive I have 98 I want
to play e5 oh wait Bishop f4 was illegal
here the plan on d2 still has a pawn in
d - so maybe Bishop g4 ok Benoni stuff
is happening oh I could trade on f3 deep
and then play some crazy stuff I mean
there's no time to thinks I'm going to
do it hope for the best
another sub luge addenda Jen thanks for
subbing takes takes e4 and then d3 and
then I'm just completely overextended
and why has a bishop air if I don't do
that I lose a pawn on d4 so this is not
a great position but what else do I do I
could maybe just take and reinforce I
should see five maybe okay almost down a
minute on the clock but the positions
okay and you for probably would have
been a mistake
want to play Queen d7 and rook a d8
probably White has a bishop pair but
it's not too deadly yet Mike's kind of
out of play but it's also kind of an
outpost though maybe I have idea of like
moving my knight in c6
someday so he takes whoa b7 is kind of
hanging in some lines h3 too so we could
tray the bunch
some weird lines maybe I just take with
pawn probably didn't you just spend that
much time
okay Rupp d8 will come reinforcing the
pawn now I want to move my nights and
play c6 maybe 95 he wants to play d4
before is controlled for the time being
Queen d2 okay oh there's some trick 95
in Queen takes h3 well it's $50 but I
can't I have to stay focused 50 dollars
out of nowhere 95 takes wait 95 what's
online 95 before it's so complicated
95 before it takes takes doesn't feel
right oh maybe C 3 though I think I have
C 3 so before I play I either take for a
sorry place c c6 first we trade them
that I have Queen takes h3 in the end
crazy line so long time this is not a
good position to be a long time and
going for craziness so I don't know if
I'm even winning a pawn but okay oh I
could also take on b5 maybe taking on b5
might be better more valuable pawn I
mean take queens xh3 as fancy though
taking here I mean I target c5 and d3
and if I'm me 7
um let's uh move okay my knight wants to
land on III someday either Knights wants
to land on III the promised land co taki
thanks for the $50 there's probably a
message with that
I'll check after the stream okay so 97
Oh a fives also hanging but do I care
about the queenside
kind of okay I'm ditching my queenside
pawns and going for a knight i 593 I
have to go for active play g4
interesting my Knights about to get
trapped
it's not pleasant so I could maybe it's
take play this losing a pawn very
valuable pawn to but White's kind of
overextended c-5s hanging rooks awkward
nd for some hope hopefully yeah this is
not good
he's gonna take on f6 not good that's
also a move to go for tricks d4 is a
move but okay now I'm threatening f6
good move maybe each let's play h6 I
want to play knight c6 hitting the Queen
and the bishop and kind of the pawn
Queen d2 expected let's do this now I'm
threatening to win the bishop and maybe
the pawn not the square my knight wants
to be on but that's life could take now
taking is bad let's do this okay it's
still kind of alive weights overextended
kind of want to win a three
play h5
now I want to play like Queen h4 like
one last shot if Queen b3 probably still
Queen h4 f6 Wow
not really what I wanted to do cancel my
prima that was annoying okay my paw my
kings close enough oh but he's gonna
just win the endgame King f2 is coming
not good yeah rook e8 kills me
yeah the outside passer is a very strong
thing to have an endgame unfortunately
for me any more tricks left no more
tricks left nice he's thinking kind of
how do I resign that's my first time
using the resign one the whole time good
game let me update the score that brings
him to two point five I have to keep
track of the number of games we've
played I think we've only played two
blitz games rematch I'm white I'm gonna
play another London I guess
cleany for what do I want to play let's
play that yeah let's play this so you
played some weird stuff last game
playing another London bread-and-butter
opening I've had decent success with
this so far
I'm gonna play the h3 line again play
this earlier and this time I might be a
bit trickier give a sixth time I played
Bishop d3 and I'm tempting him to sack
the pawn or to win the pawn I'm the one
sacking upon I was researching this
earlier and there's all these weird
lines I don't remember if this is
specific preparation but I know it's an
idea so and it's not bad for blitz cuz
I'm making him think like already a
critical moment if he doesn't take the
pawn he was left with kind of a passing
position so he takes a pawn I think I
just Castle I could play maybe it would
be one mmm its castle that's kind of in
the style of the Bangko gambit like the
Queen goes back and I have some more
files to play with I'm going for a more
long-term compensation also compensation
based on time - and that's all assuming
I'm not just losing immediately do I
repeat one year rugby one queen c3 rugby
three Queen moves back Bishop be one
looks playable but here's Queenie - and
then we repeat let's go for it I'm fine
with repeating somewhat of an opening
experiment Bishop d7 could be annoying
actually wait rugby or Queen C 3 or Fe 3
Queen c6 my pawns hanging my dogs
barking
well so I do I have bishop me too but
that's not the move I want to play so
rook p3 Queen C 695 I sack another pawn
this might be an opening gone wrong
maybe 95 takes him then rook b3 this is
very weird 95 takes rook b3 but he takes
on f 2 it's a problem so what else
I really have much else let's play with
b3 I almost mouselook their integrity to
I could defend the pawn like I can just
my business defended the Queen a one
play Queen a one so I didn't really want
to give away my LightSquared bishop but
doing the best I can because now I get
the e5 square and blacks a little bit
slow to develop on the Queen side rook
c1 in the air a five in the air
squirrels outside
okay start with 95 probably have to take
this some points Queen you six maybe a
five maybe six also a rugby one does
that
it's take and play rook b3 I wanna bring
the knight to be six maybe up a little
bit of time you can't play a five
because I just take
now the bishops kind of stuck rook can't
really go to be it because my bishops on
g3 Brook PA I probably played Knight
takes off seven meantime I want to play
rook c1 also in the meantime he's
thinking which is good well also maybe
play queen bee one target efore lots of
ideas another arrow worthy position like
queen bee one night c4 Knight b6 rook c1
c4 is a targets so he plays a5 wants to
play rook a6 probably let's start with
queen pawn hangs so let's start with
this I should be for interesting good
move
the queen is tied down let's do this
some idea of like taking on b4 and
playing Bishop d6
what else takes
let's do maybe Bishop e5 she really
don't know what to do here
gonna put the rook on the C file I'll
have a Bishop g7 scumming okay at least
I can attack the pawn now probably f5
okay so we're trading b7 as attacked
maybe Queen g4 just go for the King side
attack if f5 probably Queen e2 point h4
+ f6 play h4 maybe Knight d6 happy to
get the Ox of color bishops that's a
good move maybe this does that do
anything I think that does anything not
good let's put the rook put this back
actually the bishop here
time scramble I'm so slow with these
pieces let's play this let's play this
this is not looking good I still have
hope efore very hopeful move there's
actually a good deal of hope here so you
slide down to u6 so we're gonna trade
just what I wanted
pawns are kind of fixed on not the best
squares Tommy do I have an active rook
maybe like g4g five blocks kind of stuck
let me play after three Chuck I'm happy
with a draw we draw okay so it is what's
the score four and a half or four to
three actually we played that was our
third blitz game we have five worklets
games and then ten Bullock games man
bull it's gonna be a blood
what's a mud show mud slinging fest but
three two okay some interesting games so
far I'm sure things were missed a key
for both of us probably for him
oh did I get a challenge maybe I got a
challenge oh except okay I'm white again
yeah it's this weird thing like it
usually should alternate colors but it's
random so like half the time I'll be the
same color in a row except okay okay d4
let's see what we have let's stick with
my usual repertory qgg first time
playing one of these in the match I'm
gonna play a six kind of a pack line
there's a few ways for wait to meet this
let's take yeah this is one of the main
lines it's play rook here 9f8 coming
soon
it's making sure I'm not messing up the
move order pretty sure this is still
prep c6 will come soon Knight g6 will
come soon yeah review one is typical
let's start with this I believe and then
this so now the plan is to play Bishop
d6
and then h6 this is still preparation
there's actually a nice idea coming up
if he walks into like the main line I
think I have a study on this on me chess
I show this whole line it's called how
to play against one d4 and the the
critical variation is when white plays
d4 usually after trading on c6 and then
there's some relatively like new
computer move after E for like very
incredible move but I don't know if he's
gonna do it rook b6 that's a new move I
could play Bishop c7 I mean he's not
threatening to take I have tactics
I could play maybe Bishop g4 he's played
Bishop g4 yeah repeats looks I've never
seen before but that's probably a good
thing it's not the most challenging move
I would think but it's still gonna be
interesting like 92 and now that's a
question how I attack maybe Bishop
Bishop c7 Queen d6
he wants to take on d5 maybe but then I
take let's see if he takes on d5 cute
trap
he takes 25 I take on each - I might
want to play tonight h4 soon waiver goes
back whoa
am I just winning here or no it's still
complicated ah he wins g6 actually so
this might not even be good for me yeah
this is just not good for me oh man I
have to go for this do I have any tricks
Queen b6 now
yeah I'm gonna be down upon maybe two
he's winning g6 take with rook or queen
me rookie seven guarding the seventh
rank want to bring the other ear up to
f8
some idea Rick our faith in Bishop e2 at
least I have time I move so quickly in
the opening if g3 I probably play Queen
h3 there's some fight as long as a
knight can't get to e5 plays f3 okay I
have to move the bishop probably back
here anything else
Queens attacked and III is attacked I'm
expecting Queen f5 and then I'll
probably play Bishop at 7 oh that's a
good move I can still play Bishop f7 I
think my play g3 it's looking shaky g3
Queen g5 hold on I want to play rook a
e8 next so he wants to trade okay we can
trade you three still attacked
he doesn't have rookie one wing is Queen
b3 now what to do want to attack the
pawn again maybe this first like Bishop
g6 and just be solid I'll see what he
does maybe H 5 H 4 and I'm down upon be
happy with a draw I can hold it
Brookes gonna activate probably I have
rook f7 may be attack the F pawn he's
gonna put the Queen on f2 so let's put
the rook on c2 my play Brooke c1 let's
put the rook here he's gonna play Queen
g3 that's okay you can trade I play h4
okay in this case I play that while
going for the kill or the center
expansion Bishop e8 is really
interesting so v8 mmm I'm sure if it
doesn't much
ticks ticks push let's push getting low
on time no tactics I have to trade to
take stakes no well maybe I can win upon
we work here
by winning upon be so happy if I can win
a plot been down upon for so long his
night doesn't have access to squares now
my king is close enough a bishop he ate
if necessary let's not go crazy let's
put the king in the center
restrict the Knights okay let's just
draw this
be careful
whoa why did it scroll up all the way I
don't like how the draw button is right
next to the resign button it's just
asking for like a disaster okay let me
update the score four and a half to
three and a half rematch
okay you gain could play you for play
you for and see what he does playing my
pet line I was gonna save this for
bullets but I feels like a good time
either break from the London oh do I
play the Halloween gamete I have to play
the homing gannets I have to such a fun
opening I don't think I've played that
against GM but first time for everything
I think I do this and then just keep
pushing
I mean he might play Bishop g7 if he
wants to be boring and then we just have
a game yeah that's how GM's treat the
Halloween
that's a playable position for both of
us maybe each three preventing like
stuff that's a move normally I would
like to play Bishop III but my pawns on
a3 so I could take could take and maybe
e5 is interesting I'm just still trying
to play in a spicy fashion b5 we trade
some more let's do it it's a positional
sacrifice want to give black two sets of
double isolated pawns and I'll probably
play Bishop g5 if he takes doesn't take
doesn't want my material that I'm
gifting him probably not a bad decision
we could trade here
trade trade 95 is a good move okay we're
gonna do some trading more Trading black
will have Center pawns I'll have half
open Center files if anything blacks
probably slightly in that area but
hopefully not buy too much
that's a reasonable move Bishop here I
don't know I need to develop this is
actually kind of an annoying position
pouring message 'if I've so he wants to
play D for D for this is gonna be
painful maybe before at first before
before actually looks really interesting
before we trade cuz I want to gather
Bishop to c5
he's not gonna allow it but if he plays
d4 we trade some more looks playable
okay so let's take two take yeah maybe
Queen b3 and rook c1
it's still double-edged I mean not sure
if the pawn favors black probably does a
little bit but it gives me some chances
to could be a weakness oh I forgot about
that move it's a very strong move did I
have Trixie's bishop it takes in Bishop
g5 and I have to go for this Bishop me
seven tricks and if I go then Bishop e7
and get the Bishop to b4 it should be
okay I would hope yeah let's go for this
and I'm probably preferable here those
Box pawns are potential weaknesses
bishops of the same color he wants to
play Bishop b2 so maybe first I attacked
the pawn rook d5 it's still complicated
he also wants to play Bishop d4 so let's
do this first if there should be two I
have Bishop c3 I think this is probably
going to liquidate into a draw somehow
but I'm still sharp for both of us let's
do this
this would be for just rip d2 any time I
can play Bishop c3 and simplify
maybe king of foreign soon I want to
play like bishops III maybe right now
I wrote d2 first Bishop c3
not sure if that was the right decision
but he wants to avoid the trade could go
after the B Kong maybe do this the
bishops gonna come see Bishop c5 I take
on b5 Bishop let's try this
I've won a few like endings Rock endings
and some nice ways he's low on time I'm
also a long time but he's more low on
time t2 doesn't quite work to trade a
pair of rooks activate this rook maybe I
think I'm threatening f4 actually a nice
move let's play this I had kini too
should play kini to do I just moved back
probably just move back yeah we're
simplifying
wait really so it's still okay can play
this out a little bit
ih for maybe up three and then G for
I'm actually playing for a win now I
want to get my team to g5 ever cheat so
I have king of six now I'm winning a
pawn I think so you when I get back
maybe not what to do let's do this
no in this wait am i what's going on
here
check
no this is just a draw
yeah okay I tried that
as close to a win I want a pond kind of
modify the text that's five to four
played nine games so we still have a few
more blitz games rematch lava chess so
the first four okay so we have three
more blood schemes and then ten bowl
games and then we'll be we'll be done
you send the chat oh he sent a challenge
except okay I'm black okay let's play
c5 mmm close Sicilian play six
okay so he's playing a tricky move order
might get the same thing
there should be five it's playable
Bishop do you through yeah I think it
moves a six and then knight c6 is kind
of funny
and b3 okay I don't really have too much
prep here but we'll get some position in
Queen c7 it's not really a dangerous
line it's just I don't kind of random
playable line I play this I can play
this it's funny I move my knight a bunch
of times but it stops d4 I might just
want to grab the bishop hair if he takes
and I win efore let's play b5
I want to get the bishop to be seven and
he's not gonna take I like the position
maybe Bishop d6 even or maybe rook rook
c8 playable take sticks when c2 could do
that you might play rook c1 and then I
probably take on f3 also ideas of Knight
g4 g3 Wow
let's play Bishop g2 okay this is
complete developments Castle
nyeeehhh to takes ticks or go back maybe
taking d5 yeah that looks reasonable if
a five the position transforms okay the
position transforms so white has some
potential attack I could play it maybe
d4 I think I will trade off the bishops
also block his Bishop also e5 is kind of
weak now threatening Knight takes e5 at
some points have some time advantage
okay
[Music]
Hiroki 838 we're up t8 makes a little
more sense want to put something on FAS
but I'm not sure what a4 is a good move
I play c4 c4 it takes takes takes I lose
d4 though maybe maneuvering the knight
to c6 it also played b4 maybe before it
makes the most sense
looks anti positional but ok the a file
is gonna open in White's favor if I
didn't do that
now maybe my knight can't or to d5 and
then I put my bishop on g5 and try and
play like good night versus bad bishop
let's start with this
I want to reconfigure my pieces I want
to play rook d7 and put the bishop on c7
let's not get meted now h5 there's
always night g6 should be okay I was
smart by him
cuz now there's a target on h6 but I
have bishop here there's not h3 though
not super comfortable be queen here I
want to play Bishop g5 soon
tradeoff like one pair of miners maybe
queen d8 soon 28 97 really control g5
and then a force coming my knight needs
a happier home i could break through
maybe
I'll put the rook on d5 for now the
Queen on d8 maybe d7 and just hold tight
I have to play King they're stopping
right f6 96 is probably coming I don't
quite have f5 let's do this
I want to get my Knight to d5 it's a
slow process
it's about to happen or we're trading
nights she's also fine with me Queen a a
king h7c is being bold move the rook
back maybe put the Queen good trade
Queens fine with that too I'm just gonna
hunker down and maybe hole over push or
maybe hope I'll play me mmm takes takes
the king up
okay I don't want to run into f5 it
happens anyway
okay now I'm turning f6 I think like
you're up g5s 6 u 6 I just take it let's
not hang anything be King h6 now f6 oh
it's just trading let's do this so I
want to play f6 maybe now risky decision
okay being active rook g7 King h8 she
wants to trade avoiding trading both
rooks are scary all their works on the
board are scary
it's due this was probably a bad move
check he's meeting me no no oh he didn't
meet me though he had mates flagged oh
he had made them like three their final
position wasn't looking so good but I
should not flag there okay five two five
we have two more blitz games this is
going on for a while he started about
two and a half hours ago so this whole
match will probably last like three
hours okay I'm white scrolling okay
let's play a London again
now I'm happy that he's deviating of a
new line each for very trendy these days
I mean most GM's should have like some
idea what to do here is black so he
castles 95 right away is normal 95 right
away I think so
c5 I might just take it
it's from you got Jess thanks for the
bits need some energy I forgot to make
tea beforehand so I'm relying on water
that's the move can i play Queen D for
Queen D for is interesting ideas of B
for it looks wrong
he's my play 96 but let's try it this is
something I should like prepare ahead of
time it looks really interesting because
if I get before and I mean White's great
just a question can black do anything 96
I take I don't know
it's thinking though it's good sign
up a minute I should be thinking - I
don't know what he's gonna do
my ft7 ah so before Queen c7 I take on
d5 who's this
Oh then he takes on e5 wait looks fine I
don't understand this looks nice for
white unless he wants to play queen d8
then I can take oh that's actually
tricky
yeah Queen d8 can I take on d5 with a
knight this is very messy I take with
Queen he takes and that's bad or is it
takes yeah that's probably bad I mean
what's he threatening you think this
should be five as a move I rip d1 could
be a move cousin Queen side could be a
move the knight takes
he wants to take in the knight c6 so I
have to do something else play Bishop e5
I think it defends against whatever he
was trying to do which is mainly taking
in 96
a5 is fanatic maybe I can take on d5
things are just so messy I mean I'm
controlling the center that's good thing
right that would be a good thing ready
to castle either way
probably Kings side mom okay let's
castle first I guess get the King safe
connect the rooks I'm up one pawn
temporarily but pawn structure is a bit
weird might be six as a move
looks okay
okay wait should be better here I don't
know by how much but I have a lot of
time which is always nice
Black's a bit struggling to develop new
tactics here maybe see four takes an A
for interesting idea as I shouldn't win
the C pawn at some points in my bishop
and Knight restrict his bishop and
knights on the Queen side just quite
nice now I win I mean I'm maybe trapping
the rook when's that oh wait no I take
in the night c4 and I chop the rook
there we go puzzle rush type thing let's
play this because if Ric moves up I win
the bishop it was that way
96 probably and then R okay coming not
over yet cuz Bishop d7
there's my time let's do that and this
ninety-three scary let's do this I want
to push the beep on and play rook eight
we're both trying to Queen I think on
queening more effectively
let's take with check first then take
the Queen and then promote and I'll be
able to queen man that's a big Queen
okay six to five I think there's one
more books game this is a lot of chess
okay before I'm gonna play another
Cecilia and I'm gonna save my dirty
tricks for bullets another Knight c3
Sicilian last time you played Knight f3
we have it again there should be five
again okay this time I'll play knight c6
not giving them the option of taking I'm
fine with a draw if he wants to repeat a
six and okay very similar line Bishop e2
this is where I play Knight d4 so we
were lying but I studied this a few
months ago in Australia I actually
studied it for the white side but I
remember liking it for black II five
well to move take stakes
maybe I shouldn't allow e5
it's bits from naked Yeti thanks naked
Yeti takes takes there okay let's take
and play night here yeah maybe I should
have started with some earlier Queen c7
yeah cuz this is a little bit difficult
I want to develop I also want to make
sure I'm not getting crushed or like
losing a pawn d4 is a good move if I get
like four moves in a row and Castle and
play d6 I'll be happy it takes a lot of
moves to be happy
it should be seven problem is if he
leaves us pawn on d4 my bishops just
kind of a depressed piece
okay so let's castle let me gather rip
to c8 Carolyn age six maybe wants to
play does he want to play I don't know
what he wants to play let's play rook c8
see green g5 I just take it nice Ivan I
have h6 maybe a five soon like a five a
four ideas ambition a six I use
it's a good move do this I have to do
something you might play a four then I
can probably play c4 okay let's do this
problem is stuff that's happening like
Knight g5 rook g3 I should probably look
at the King side Knight g5 I have Queen
h6 welp on time which is good let's take
first and play rook AIDS maybe rotate
one attack from the rear
put my other rook on AIDS
okay Queen h6 I believe our queen this
is looking very scary and maybe just bad
for me if somewhere I play rook e1 maybe
it's okay that Bishop needs to come to
life needs to get a life
so d6 bishop c8 know what to do where's
my counter play EP bishop c6 defending
the pawn
I have the chance maybe I'll pawn storm
that's terrifying
five doesn't help let's do this maybe I
can play Rock f1 defend from the rear
raka Florrick aa1 it's something getting
lower on time looks are finding some
coordination the outs do this rook is so
random on f1 you might play rook e1 and
just trade a pair but then I have Queen
g6 hit some points let's play clean g6
do I take or do I play Queen each six
probably take even though I don't want
to take I'm allowing d5 but that's okay
I think because I have the [ __ ] back and
then be five or maybe even wrote a five
it's really not that bad
Roque fives of threats White has space
but it's endgame okay five I'm winning
upon maybe tricks its take take maybe
King here it's very tricky position
yeah how'd you six I was scared of I'm a
beer up t5i bishop You Danny for takes
takes takes they're 35 this is so
confusing let's do this once
55 of gonna trade rooks and push the
b-pawn attack the Jeep on I was a good
news but he loses G pawn to defend
somehow the H pawn oh he has some clear
plan how do I defend
this is so bad okay not looking too
hopeful trying though
I resign good game that was a crazy end
game so it's six to six heading into the
bullet portion oh boy I don't know how
this is gonna work I have a challenge
I'll wait for his challenge in the
meantime thanks to people who were
cheering and subbing and donating okay
not too much time to think people this
is the beginning of one minute chess
good luck
and we're off okay 9 f3 I think ok let's
play something let's take and play this
line yeah the exchange sack line
interesting variation it's been a while
since I've played this maybe Bishop a6
and B 4
this is not my own turf when it comes to
bullet Ches I'm trying let's defend the
pawn ah but he wins that let's play this
I want to take on before with something
let's take here and then that I'm so
slow though let's take take that way
let's do that this I'm losing my disap
oh man I have no feel for like peace
movement it's just it's a little bit
laggy and I'm yeah I resign okay this is
going to be rough so that's six to seven
rematch I've I have a bad feeling about
this
okay let's play another efore I really
just have to play reasonable moves and
not plunder died already blunder may
have already blundered but there's
compensation I hope that'll be
compensation
I'm winning a pawn back oh wait what I'm
doing bored visions just terrible let's
do this that's not the move I wanted to
play
only hope is to like dirty flag them
somehow Quinn a 1.88 and get some
perpetual maybe where's my perpetual
there goes my queen so how long does pre
moving take like does it take off time
Jiji this is rough okay
well people can see the score here so
I'm not going to update the score after
every game I'm down by two this is
really tough let's play a staff for
gambit okay this is my own territory
that's fine with me
oh I blundered I have to treat this as a
Halloween gambit now wait that's fine
with me
okay it was weird oh it's so hard to
move these pieces may feel heavy let's
play this let's move back
let's take and do Bishop d6 move back
like that I could take and trade more c6
I'm losing beasts a sudden William take
it not the highest quality chess c5 oh
my gosh losing two pawns you slimy
I'm not even playing faster than them
I'm winning back i and now my Knights in
the center you do that and this have a
blockade of some sort
try and win the c-pawn
do that kind of holding my own do that
let's do this
what's the ruling for this am I gonna
win on time oh that was a draw draw as
Oh I ran out of time but had
insufficient meeting material okay six
and a half eight and a half first bullet
game I didn't lose
is there a settings the problem is like
the animation speed is slow and I can't
like that thing physically won't move
yeah what to do okay London time let's
play this line to play aggressively so
the game doesn't come down to a time
scramble
it's Castle Queen d2 coming let's play a
four and a five and night here my pawns
hanging but he hasn't been taking it in
the night here maybe be three not the
move I wanted to play but I'm trying to
be solid I don't like how it cancels the
pre move but what to do
g4 okay I'm going crazy after
breakthrough I try and break through
threatening to take the knight if he
moves him might I have the h5 that was a
good move
let's check and take and hope for the
best
uh-oh I can win the night so he found
safety for the King kind of let's do
this
this is bad this is receive a hat but
I'm still alive somehow let's run away
this way
it's all about slowing down the opponent
oh this is so dirty okay really I think
the first to 11 wins still 11
so I came upon he doesn't take it just
have to pre move in home I'm not blind
drinking let's play f4 this is an
intentional sacrifice let's play this ok
I'm up on time I'm up like 5 seconds
let's do this have to hold on so you may
take a seven oh he wants to trade not a
bad strategy
well I'm up on time doing a quick uh not
looking so good please still make me
please
good game okay rematch
thankfully I we agreed to only ten
bullet games and not more how do we
rematch
where's every match button well I can
update the score wait new no I don't
want to press a new game so I type in
can you challenge oh there we go okay so
I think I'm one loss away from losing
the match hopefully the earlier part of
the match was more instructive okay we
have out two Knights attack French
defense yeah this is one of the main
lines this is actually fun for a bullet
Bishop d6 I think I can do this and then
it's playroom no not row g1 was ready
one I'm down apiece let's pretend I'm
giving piece odds it's not trade Queens
I had my Brooks ready to pawn storm
let's move back I don't even have like
hope on time let's move back this way
move this way oh my gosh I resign just
rematch ok this is gonna be over very
shortly I have just a few more games so
I'm just trying to play like a normal
setup going for c5 and rook here maybe
rook c8
okay this is a reasonable position
actually I'm down five seconds but
position it's not that bad play Bishop
f8
maybe c4 soon c4 is interesting
we're gonna trade a lot and I might just
be losing here yeah it's a very strong
move let's play this still gonna try
maybe this wait am i coming back he's
ripped III could move
okay this is my try he has to defend
something I don't like that do this six
this this this I'm really trying as hard
as I can pre moving a lot
I just want to flag him pretty sure you
waste time for each Cree move okay I
want to game on time are we done yet
Stephon and a half 19 - okay wait 19
can I count no are twenty games we play
22 maybe I can cancel and accept okay
okay I'm gonna play this line again try
and makes us close d3 what was d3 oh
he's just playing kind of the same setup
maneuver the knight to the Kings side
now I'm feeling slightly faster trying
to get used to this
let's take and play each 5h4 want to
create a hole on f4 and then I'll play
Knight h5 now I've kind of feel like I
can focus on the chest rather than just
focusing on trying to make legal moves
let's do this move move of Bishop could
maybe play b6 have some time advantage
take and play rook t4 ban I want to open
the bishop on c7 now do this and attack
g3 let's take and then take a few more
times to the some queen a8 spycheck
nevermind let's do this and maybe i-5
he's attacking me stop it okay let's do
this in g4 he played g4 it's dude I hung
a bishop no I'm getting spy checks kind
of
such dirtiness okay I flagged him
another time we have one more game right
into one more game 4 plus 8 plus 10
that's 22
we've played 2012 oh we played 20 games
ok last game see if I can finish strong
oh he's challenging me
ok guess will manually accept let's play
E 4 d 6 let's be aggressive this time
I'm gonna play the line with those are
aligned with G 4 I think there's a line
with G 4 right
looks playable they can think well the G
pawns defended now it's not defendants
maybe no that's bad let's do this ok my
time is bad my positions not great I'm
hopeful might have 5 meeting and then f4
coming soon
g4 pawn storm
let's take I'm attacking a seven and
winning a seven maybe I can do this in
94 and 96 forgot about that
check do some dancing
he wants to fork me let's not get forked
let's do this let's do this such a mess
I'm using material but I'm up on time a
little bit
I slowed them down just enough weight I
lost on time I thought I had one on time
oh okay I think we're done
thankfully well the Blitz and the rapid
wer were actually like interesting
bullet was just a mess but
congratulations Pappa Cuenca beating me
what was the final score I ragequit that
window I don't think I he had 12 and a
half I think okay final score 12 and a
half have to do some math to aid in the
house does that make any sense
21 games we played 22 oh wait we have
one more game I forgot we played 22
games total or are we done except I
think we have one more game
okay I'll update the score after this B
3 let's play h5 play d3 and multiply H 3
if I've pushed my Brooke pons hoping for
the best maybe he'll fall for the bait
let's take and play this I'm just going
for Sun like pots her attack
he's defusing things well still want the
file to open let's do that I hung a rook
please don't take it now he took it the
queen h7 would have destroyed me but now
I'm coming back to life see two's
falling I might be mating white was this
okay I think I'm winning this up on time
and position and about to meet kind of
there we go
are we done nine and a half to twelve
and a half
I lost the match but I survived the
match yeah that adds up to 22 yeah good
uh good games
it's bits from something ah police let
me update the final score I'm pretty
sure I don't know people people should
have been aware but Pepe was also
streaming this I don't know if it was on
Twitch I know it was on YouTube
yeah it was with Paulie canes were a
struggle I don't think this site is
optimized for bullets but okay I'll
probably put the full thing on YouTube I
did getting rating I passed 2,000 and
bullet because I I mean today was my
first day playing on the sights so I
hope people enjoy that I'll probably do
more matches in the future um I'll
probably stick with me chess in the
future at least four bullets but it's
more bits from you got chess I really
was not looking at the check for the
last three hours so I don't know what I
missed
can't decide which stream to watch yeah
they should have been streaming on
Twitch and then we could have done multi
twitch but you can I how many people
were watching like on two separate tabs
you just listen to both of us at the
same time so I feel like that's the best
way of doing things that's really what
multi twitches for I think so fucsia for
sharing the youtube link for st. Louis
chess club yeah one thing if people
aren't familiar with Pepe Cuenca he's
probably one of the most exciting most
like emotional Spanish commentators I
would assume he was commentating on
English throughout this match but
there's some viral like clip of him like
doing Spanish commentary for the World
Championship I have to find it and like
retweeted or something but yeah good
games there's a lot of London openings
anyone who plays a London those are some
interesting games to look at but we have
a good variety of openings most notable
opening was probably the Halloween
gambits that he eventually just gave
material I think he won that game do you
in that game
that game was a draw I don't know how to
go back and look at the games but try
and figure out how to do that later
in the meantime I'm in the wrap things
up I do want to thank tio talk again if
you're in the chats thanks so much for
donating $50 out of nowhere maybe I have
the stream labs you see if I have stream
labs see what he said a lot of new
followers ot at walkie said a long time
viewer first time catching the stream
thanks for all the great content well
thank you so gonna wrap things up is
there anyone I can raid let me know
people in the chat let me know who to
rate there's some questions hey Eric
why are you playing on the different
sites yeah Pepe does content for chess
24 so he requested that we play here
which I mean I'm happy to try out new
platforms honestly I didn't know chess
24 had like a playing platform I know
they do a lot of like broadcasts for
tournaments they have instructional
videos well yeah bull it was a bit of a
challenge but overall I think it worked
out anything else is an adjusting and a
chess what's her actual like twitch
username is it on your score and a chess
who is it just Anytus
- aha
found it there isn't underscore okay
guys have fun watching Anna chess for
anyone who's subbed to me she really
likes a fork knight emotes so if you
join the raid
use the fork knight emotes and you shall
be very happy I'll see you guys in the
future